they would lock people in there the
doors
were studied just like a cheese grater
no no food hole studied just like a
cheese grater reason being
you want to bang on the door say please
let me out i want you to let me out you
your hands get torn i just thought what
is the refinement
of cruelty that enables you to design
something like this
[Music]
hello and welcome to trigonometry i'm
francis foster i'm constantine kissen
and this is a show for you if you want
honest conversations with fascinating
people we are delighted to have a
brilliant guest for you today he's a
british historian and the author of
labor and the gulags russia and the
seduction of the british left giles yudy
welcome to trigonometry it's good to be
here thanks so much for inviting me oh
it's such a pleasure to have you on i'm
really looking forward to this
conversation for anyone who's unfamiliar
with you your story your work tell
everybody a little bit about who are you
it's been your journey through life that
leads you to be sitting here talking to
us well i had uh probably conventional
middle class background i was shipped
off to boarding school
spent 10 years there
messed up most of my time at school for
like my a levels
got to uni
thrown out of uni for not working hard
enough when i just kind of drifted
i drifted around i did a few jobs i
ended up by working in the shipping
industry for quite a while and i'd done
a number of things over the years uh and
that just continued a bit of this i was
hoping to set up a business with someone
and then i spent some years in
construction building and then about 20
years ago i happened to
take part in a trip to russia
and i didn't know because actually i
didn't really want to go by the end and
i almost ducked out i didn't know it was
going to be you know the thing that
changed the whole course of my life the
whole direction
and
i was we were going with a party of
people who were helping after the fall
of communism just to rebuild independent
churches because of course one of the
pillars of civil society being
completely ripped out under communism it
was basically illegal to to worship in a
church uh and um and so we went over
there i was just helping with a
conference you know hanging around at
the back talking to people
and uh
i did a bit of reading before i went
i'd missed
well i didn't do history i'm a historian
now but i didn't even do history day
level i dropped it as soon as i could at
gcse and i had done some reading before
i went and i thought this is astonishing
that any people can go through
this kind of suffering for decade after
decade after decade the the level of
repression the
dictatorship the fear the deaths
i was just you know i was it's
how can you how can you how can you meet
people today who've been through all of
that or their parents have or you know
in those days you could sit around a
table in russia with a group of or just
ordinary people my age and and you'd say
so do any of you have any experience of
of of the gulag era and of you know
repression and what's happened to your
family and some would say oh yeah my my
my grandpa's brother was shot yeah well
well my grandparents uh they were in the
camps um oh and once chap i remember
saying to me oh yeah stalin wiped out
half my family and you go around the
table and maybe a third of the people
there would have some story like that in
their family background fairly immediate
family background and of course too the
thing about those things is is you know
you've got somebody who's been in a
prison camp a soviet prison camp for for
15 years they come out and they are
pretty damaged so they have their own
family or they have their own children
maybe they're reunited so you've got
kids brought up in that and then it kind
of goes on through the generations
anyway
i was in this i was in this this
conference and i happened to make
contact with uh
with some people who
they came from an uh this northern city
way way high up above the arctic circle
if you take a straight line from
afghanistan and you go all the way up to
the arctic circle then go 300 miles
north
and you get to this crazy city in the
middle of nowhere called narilsk and it
sits on one third of the world's
reserves of vehicle and i just got
fascinated because it was one of the big
nasty gulag centers there were maybe
four or five really really horrible camp
complexes you know multiple camps but i
mean this one was so isolated and i just
got fascinated by the story of it and i
got them eventually to be able to get me
in you needed a kgb permit to do so
and i'll come to that very very briefly
in a minute but anyway i i just
i got i got transfixed by this story
this was this is a city that is 300
miles above the arctic circle the the
permafrost is 300 meters deep that's
frozen solid ice temperature goes down
never melts temperature goes down to
minus 50 in the winter um right now
they've just got two hours of sunshine
and they'll go through six weeks of dark
and then you get to the summer and it's
bright sunshine i got there in the end
and i remember sitting on the top of the
low of the nearest mountain 11 30 at
night in bright sunshine i mean the sun
by then just goes round in a circle all
the way around it doesn't stop but as i
discovered more and more about the city
and its history and i i i just thought
oh wow there's a story to be told here
because so many different groups of
people over the 20 years or so that it
was in existence uh 20 30. yeah about 20
25 years it was in existence so many
different groups of people have been
there
poles who'd been shipped out by stalin
um
russian prisoners of war
red army prisoners of war who just been
dumped there a lot of ukrainian
nationalists towards the end baltic
people old bolsheviks comrades of lenin
uh from the old days those ones that
hadn't been shot and a lot of them had
been shot but but those ones they were
all there and i just thought there's so
many stories here i've got to i've got
to i've got to dig deeper and i managed
to get in the the first year i couldn't
get in
the first year i thought i i bet then
i'd been reading so many memoirs so i
thought i need
i need to follow the path of the
prisoners i need to understand what it
was like a little bit of what they do so
i i flew out to
so the geographical center of russia
krasnayas which is right in the middle
of siberia and there i caught the last
ferry north
um
i was the only english speaker on board
i didn't speak any russian
i mean my russian friends think i was
crazy to do it but i you know it's the
story gripped me and it was a
thousand mile journey north on this
river we just got no idea in this
country you know the thames is big this
is big you get a thousand miles north
the roads run out at 300 miles so then
you've got nothing except for the river
and then that freezes from maybe october
november through to april um and then
these little villages they're all
isolated but i knew the stories even of
the people who had been deported to
those villages
uh and you know so we just we go all the
way north and past some of these places
there was one group of camps which i
knew of
and you know it was an extraordinary
moving thing
we're in the middle of this river which
is a mile wide at that stage and you
just see this big blue cross
among the trees on the side and you
think
wow
you know shivers down my spine even when
i'm talking about it those sorts of
things so then i got into the city um i
this is going on a long time i'll be as
quick as i can
but i got into the city the next year
and
um it was hard enough to get a permit
but it just so happened the guy had made
contact with uh ran the local telephone
company and he had enough clout with the
uh fsb with the police to be able to get
me a permit it was a secret city you
weren't allowed in without a permit and
i flew in i flew in from moscow
and all the passengers were allowed to
leave from the airplane i was kept on
the plane
and then the police arrived to escort me
on a military jeep through to the
airport police station and i was held
there until these guys who i'd never met
before but just said great you come we
are happy to welcome you because
russians are actually very very
welcoming people and the idea that
anyone wanted to come from from the
mainland as they'd call it to this
isolated place they just thought was
just great you know come on please we'd
love to have you um and so they came and
collected me and then we spent maybe a
week two weeks
uh
i said maybe i was just there for 10
days i can't remember because it was
quite a while ago but they took me round
to what still remained of these old
camps
and uh you know wouldn't barracks decay
it's a vast mining center it's a it's a
strange place because there's an immense
amount of pride there today we live in
the arctic this is great we we we
managed to stay here but at the same
time as i went there it was voted one of
the 10 most polluted cities on earth you
know you come out here flat in the
morning uh because they let me stay in a
flat and they've got a refining factory
that refines nickel at one in the city
and they've got a refining factory that
that refines copper at the other end of
the city and they they come out in the
morning go
ah yeah wins in the winds in the west
that's a copper factory and then no it's
it's the nickel factory the pollution
was so great but they took me around
they took me around some of these ruins
and um
i mean some of them were just
with the i think that the one that
struck me most was they took me to a
little outlying settlement there's 120
000 people live in this city still but
you can walk across it in 20 minutes
because it's just basically blocks of
flats and then huge mines um and then
some outlying townships they took me off
to a rubbish dump in one and then the
rubbish dump there was this concrete
construction
and what it was it was the remnants of a
punishment cell block inside a
punishment camp
now you minor infractions or major
infractions you went into punishment cap
they had you working in the quarries
brutal conditions run by convicts just
like the nazi prisoners prison camps
were run by capos you know they
it horrible places but this inside was
the worst of the worst
and because it was built in concrete
it still survived
and you went in
and you know one cell i remember was a
single cell it's just a man's length
long
and there was a bar door and then an
outer door
and he'd be kept in there total dark
the rule for punishment camp blocks was
that they took your clothes at the
beginning of the day and you're allowed
back to sleep in them at night
it didn't matter if there's no heating
uh that was it but then down
on one cord of the main corridor the
cells were open i said it's go down to
minus 50 in this place the cells were
open
and they would lock people in there the
doors
were studied just like a cheese grater
no no food hole studied just like a
cheese grater reason being
you want to bang on the door say please
let me out i want you to let me out you
your hands get torn i just thought what
is the refinement
of
cruelty that enables you to design
something like this and put it in
as part of the process in which you
repress people i mean that was the worst
bit but the long and the short of it was
that i came back
and i went back there a couple of times
more uh made lots of lovely friends and
uh and and
i i think probably then after a few
years you know i they i said i want to
write the story of this city i want to
write the story of the people who've
been there i want to write the story of
of
where they come from what that you know
that the latvian officer core
when the soviets took over latvia they
were marched out into a forest from for
joint exercises one day and they were
all shipped off in a cattle car and they
ended up in this place now this place
from where they were was further from
cairo to durban
never knowing whether their family would
ever know what happened to them
anyway i said to my friends i want to
write this story and i was all getting
ready i got piles and piles of research
files full and then i was doing a little
bit of research and i came across some
newspaper cuttings of the times in those
days they used to produce what had been
in parliament the day before and they
were talking about this this uh
problem there was with timber imported
from the white sea region
and it was actually bishops in the house
of lords trying to persuade the
government to do something about it this
was around about 1930-31
and i thought what's going on here
and another story took me off for the
next 15 years which is what actually
became my book
um and that was uh
that was discovering that in 1930 stalin
deported
one and a half to 1.8 million
land uh smallholding peasants the cool
acts and and kids learn about it in
school nowadays but they just know the
number right uh and 250 000 of them were
all sent up to this really really
isolated place again really cold just
sub-arctic just all the way around the
white sea which is the sea that that is
in between northern russia and finland
guys i'm going to interrupt you very
briefly i need to add that when you say
the word deported most people in the
west imagine someone being sent to a
different country but what you mean when
you say deported these are people in the
soviet union who were taken from their
small land holding as my family were in
ukraine
and sent to this siberian remote uh camp
for the crime of having property for the
crime of having property because
property had already been banned under
the 1980
under bolshevik then
later the soviet it had been banned at
the 1980 constitution but until stalin
came to power he hadn't actually got the
power to really bring that into being so
he was nationalizing all farmland
and these people they had lived in these
villages you know probably knowing
nothing outside the village
very primitive life surviving just hand
to mouth
one cow
uh one pig
uh whatever
having possession of machinery a sewing
machine was sufficient to get you picked
up i mean a sewing machine for goodness
sake and they would be taken just a few
hours notice not knowing what was going
to happen uh soldiers would just turn up
take them
and then they'd be put on a cattle truck
in whatever clothes they had
and then shipped north and the north was
was so isolated it wasn't it wasn't
ready to receive uh any any any of these
these people at a year's notice let
alone a few weeks and so they were they
just thrown out into the snow the
conditions in the camps they were in
were just appalling some of them some of
some of these kids i've got photographs
of kids who did not even have shoes
it goes down to minus 20 in the winter
well
one soviet uh
official actually wrote reports back to
moscow and said this is an absolutely
ghastly situation there are piles of
excrement everywhere we've got hundreds
of people somewhere else all relying on
a water supply from one well we've got
to do something uh for his pains he was
eventually shipped off to the camps and
i think he was shot a few years later
you know that just marked him out
so by the end of the first year maybe 21
000
because because disease and malnutrition
they're juicy that went
hand in hand of that 250 000 sent up
there maybe 21 000 were dead by the end
of the first year
absolutely awful
they were sent up there to earn foreign
currency by cutting timber for the
export trade
and we in great britain were the biggest
customer we took a million tonnes a year
it was about 500 million pounds worth of
today's prices
and the word got out stairways got on
board
those ones that weren't found and shot
others managed to escape over the
finnish border actually slogging their
way through the forest extraordinary
stories some of them there
and then they gave signed affidavits to
diplomats in helsinki
so so so the story started to come out
but it just so happened we just got our
second labor government
and the whole history as i was later
discovered the whole history of the
labour party in the interwar years is
one really of um believing that stalin
lenin first and stalin were creating the
utopian state
and um and and so what happened is uh
this massive campaign started it's
actually started by churchman but but
two 300 meetings up and down the country
in the first year a massive rally with 5
000 people in the albert hall to launch
it we don't talk about it now because
it's just one of those things that
doesn't interest the historians who are
looking at that period their idea of a
protest was a day of prayer right it was
joined in by a million people around the
globe biggest protest against soviet
communism in history right until the
fall of communism
in saint peter's square in rome 50 000
people gathered on a wednesday for a
mass that's kind of the way people
looked at church and religion in those
days well the labor government did not
want to
know they knew what was going on because
i've seen the reports that came through
but they they they either denied them or
um they were they were eventually
pressed to have a um
to have it um an
inquiry and and the foreign secretary
told the cabinet he said
if we do have an inquiry it's going to
show that forced labor is being used up
but we can't do that
and we can't do that because it might
affect our trade elsewhere in the empire
actually i've got the papers of the
people from the trade ministry the board
of trade advising him beforehand that
isn't going to be a problem but that was
a good excuse so then they sent their
their their spokesman to the parliament
just about a week later
and there they denied that there was any
evidence for what was going on a week
before in cabinet they'd actually been
talking about how the russian stairways
didn't want to get sent back because
they thought they were going to be shot
and the home secretary said i think
they're right there will be
so i saw this extraordinary hypocrisy
and then
and eventually eventually the
conservatives
you know it's funny we talk about how
unrepresentative the house of lords was
but the labour party had the majority in
the house of commons so they they
blocked every single possible
possibility of a debate it was in the
house of lords that all this agitation
was going on
really i mean i don't know what i think
about the house of lords today but
that's a fascinating challenge because
they were the only people that were
sticking up for the best part of one and
a half million working class
soviet citizens who were oppressed by
their leadership the privileged house of
lords and anglican bishops
and um uh so they met the conservatives
managed to shoehorn
one the subject into one debate
and we had uh
one labor mp george strauss
uh public school educated like so many
were in those days i mean the um the the
the deputy minister in um the foreign
office was an old etonian
get your head around that um
george strauss he said oh no no he said
well there may be there may be labor
camps going on but conditions in russian
prisons are much better than in british
prisons
uh yeah and then you know the
the cream on the cake the government
statement by a guy called and it was
george graham um he died actually flew
poor guy but otherwise he'd have been a
real high flyer so he he concluded the
debate for the government and he said um
the soviets are conducting a very
interesting economic experiment
1.8 million people
torn off their land at a few moments
notice the soviets are conducting a very
interesting social exp economic
experiment and deserve to be allowed to
continue without outside interference
indeed we will give them whatever
support they need
and i read that in hansard and i i just
i couldn't believe it i thought
you've got all the evidence i've seen it
i've now spent you know four five six
years digging through records
how could a british government
actually take that stance i mean no we
don't have a lot of faith in most
governments we're always thinking
something's you know that they're
incompetent but that was absolute
deliberate cover-up he knew i saw all
the kind of documents that were getting
sent to him i saw the reports that were
coming out um
i i just how did this happen so that
took me on another little rabbit trail
which just ended up by meaning that my
book was finally about 600 pages long or
more
because i thought how is it that we get
to that
in 1931
that doesn't come as an accident what is
it
that was going on in the years before
and
how could people
actually look at what was going on in
russia you know
people did know what was happening the
stories were coming out they were
horrifying right from the beginning i
mean for goodness sake these people shot
their royal family
men women and children
you know everyone knew that
um
and so then i just dug in and and worked
my way through all sorts of stuff and i
just
i
i couldn't believe that people could be
so consistently praising a really
evil regime there's just no way no way
to describe it and and just refusing to
see
the the stuff that was going on that was
wrong because they believed
they believed that
lenin first and then stalin was building
the great communist utopia
and we see this again and again through
the history of the labour party but my
mother's venezuelan they were all
praising travis oh yeah well you know
all about it then wouldn't you yeah so i
saw them all praising travis and you saw
owen jones and corbin and at that time
my cousin who was a journalist was
telling me that chavista chavez's thugs
were turning up at television stations
saying to journalists if you carry on
criticizing the government
you're going to feel
an unpleasant force around the back of
your head but the entire labour
government were praising it and saying
that venezuela was going to be the new
socialist paradise i came across a
newspaper cutting just yesterday
actually i don't know why it came up on
my phone which was exactly that that was
a letter that jeremy corbyn uh and
others wrote
tariq ali
tony benn signed it way back uh
commending chavez for closing down a tv
station
there you go or they all write to the
guardian they all say this is this dude
that's quite understandable
um and the same thing happened the same
thing happened i mean i
the
the guy who became the labour party
chairman in 1920s in 1946 was a man
called harold lasky incredibly famous he
was professor of political science at
the london school of economics uh he was
probably one of the two or three leading
labor intellectuals right the way
through in the period until maybe 1950
or so now 1946
he actually um
he was he was uh praising
the soviet union and saying we quite
understand that it is not a free society
but we recognize the reason why the
soviet government needs to impose these
controls
and let's be clear i'm i just i'm really
really enjoying listening to you and uh
i'm struggling emotionally because it's
difficult for me because all of these
places you talk about no reals my mother
grew up there no
she grew up there her family were there
they weren't there because they were in
a camp or anything they were there yeah
yeah yeah yeah in the 70s and it was a
very the they they told stories about
how
obviously there's no vegetables there's
no fruit so you're not getting in
vitamin c is very difficult you talk
about the permafrost those blocks are
flats they're not built on the ground
they're built on metal stilts that have
to be rammed into the permafrost and my
family my mother's family they were
kulax and
their crime was they had a horse so
people came imagine just
for people listening to this imagine you
have your house and you happen to have a
horse and some chickens and whatever and
people come along go you've got a horse
that means you're the oppressor you are
the oppressor class get out of your
house off in a cattle car you go to a
camp somewhere and um wow my grandmother
still alive 95 living in ukraine she
remembers
her little brother starving to death on
the way yeah oh
boy
and this is what happened to millions of
people
millions of people it's doing it to me
too i read these stories i read these
stories and you you
it's individuals yeah it's just not it's
not tens of thousands it's not hundreds
of thousands yeah yeah and and we're
just talking about one group the cool
act right because then you add to it you
talked about prisoners of war
let's make that clear for people what
happened was you went to fight for your
country
you went to defend the soviet union
against the nazi invasion you happen to
have been taken prisoner yeah and as a
disincentive
to being taken prisoner to encourage you
to fight for your country if you came
back after having been captured by the
germans what happened to you yeah
straight into a campaign yeah straight
filtration camps right to full trade uh
or shaw depending on what the circuit
they shot 150 000 of their own people
for military crimes during the war can
you imagine that 150 000 of your own
soldiers yeah shot by your side yeah
exactly
um and uh you know down my other down my
uh father's side my grandmother was born
in a gulag so look there's so much to
unpack
can can we just let's let's give people
some figures and some big picture stuff
first of all do you know the total
number of people who were sent into the
system yeah i do i do um the best part
of 18
million people were actually uh arrested
individually and sent to gulag camps
the other form of arrest would be by
administrative order basically an order
was given
go and round up all of that area that
city whatever or that ethnic group
particularly like in crimea or people
who'd come over with the original
germans in katherine the great stay
and they were just deported right to the
wilds of kazakhstan uh koreans on the
pacific shore also so for there you've
got maybe six million deported
and by the time you round off the figure
it's about 28 million people who were
put under some form of military
imprisonment under under guard or some
sort half of the population of modern
britain
yeah in the military indeed and if
you're going to talk about the
population in russia at the time
somewhere between one and seven and one
in ten right and of those we are sure
that about
2.75 million i mean you hear some huge
numbers yeah but but one in 10 died
if you talk about what happened to the
people who were just deported on mass
that it's about one in six
so you're talking six million deported
men women and children and and you know
maybe a million don't come back and for
the rest they're not allowed back for
decades you know way after stalin
they're still trying to get their homes
poor crimean tatars they come back they
don't get back into the 70s or 80s and
and you know now that
well that we won't talk about modern
history yet because because you can get
onto that but absolutely so we've got
2.75 million and then
in in the year 1917
1937-38 the big the great terror
uh
the nkvd secret police figures of those
shot is just under 680 000. sorry george
what's nkvd secret police i'm sorry yeah
yeah you talk about all these these they
all they all they they had different
initials right the way through the
history but the secret police uh shot
680 000 people and it's really hard to
get a grasp of what that figure is but
it just so happened uh that
this summer and you can look it up
online and see it
the um
they
they
created a monument in washington to all
the americans who died in covid up until
that time one flag per person and they
show you a a great big wide angle the
national geographic have got it up great
big wide angle shot of
all these flags this whole sea of flags
that was 670 thousand that was 10 000
less and when you see that photograph
then you it really brings it up
really brings it home that was just in
that period and giles i have this
experience of talking to people here in
the west i remember my grandmother she
had very close friends here uh who loved
her very much actually fled ngati
germany believe it or not and whenever
she told them her story about her family
they always said yeah but but why were
those people there what what did they do
it was the sort of people i think it's
very difficult to imagine this sort of
evil on this scale without thinking that
well these people at some level have
done something yeah so why were the why
were people in prison why were they sent
to these camps why were they shot what
had they done i think i think you
probably have to go back to marxism
originally to see the really low value
that was put on individual human life
um
uh humanity was considered by marx just
really as a mass
um and for the sake of building the
state
anything went and he's quite clear in
the communist manifesto
quite clear that
all
morality is as it is traditionally held
is abolished no eternal values well
eternal values are kind of the ones that
just come from the bible you know you
can't you shouldn't kill you shouldn't
murder you shouldn't do all the rest of
this stuff and then
what they then reconfigured it as is
morality what is moral is whatever aids
the revolution
so by the time you've actually just
literally abandoned every moral
constraint
it justifies any action
for the sake of building the utopia
because the marxist idea is that there
is indeed a utopia we can build
history has shown
a series of conflicts between the
classes and now we're on the last one
and the last one is the proletarian
versus the bourgeois the capitalist and
when that
conflict actually breaks out into open
warfare as it must do and the
proletarians rise up and deprive the
capitalists the bourgeois of all their
property and take it under their
ownership first and that it goes to the
state then we'll enter this kind of
heaven i mean mark's even used the
phrase heaven on earth we'll enter this
heaven on earth
and
it's a cult
it really is a cult but it possessed
these guys in russia
it possessed these guys in russia and
and once
they had the vision
you can't really back out as someone
said i don't know who it is once you've
thrust thrust the first baronet in
in in the cause of that you can't take a
step back
and so they had this idea that
everything needs to be taken under the
control of the state under the control
of people so all private trade was
banned private ownership of land was
banned but then
coupled with that there was the
possibility of of any counter revolution
of anyone actually opposing the
revolution and if you're going to impose
this total control which you believe is
eventually going to somehow morph into
this wonderful period when crime is gone
and everyone lives happily and we all
just share stuff because we want to and
no one hoards if you if you're gripped
by this
then um
then it's just a logical
step to make sure that you
get rid of every person who might oppose
it
every person who might oppose you and if
you're stalin then it's not just the
people who clearly are still part of the
old regime because most of them have
been killed or got rid of anyway the
aristocrats it's now people who might
dispute you as being the person who
could lead i mean stalin killed
so many of his colleagues you know
there's one communist convention if you
like that they were all at and and
you see the list of the the high
proportion they were just shot in the
years afterwards but so
there was there's about four purposes
behind all this repression the first was
to um punish those who really were the
enemies of the state very few of them or
were imagined to be the enemies of the
state to terrorize the rest into
compliance
and to use that slave labor and it
really was slave labor to build a new
society because
if anything goes then
people are just marshaled yeah we're
going to build a new factory well well
and in the case of nurelsk
where these that sits on one third of
the world sort of well 98 of the world's
platinum metals indeed quite possibly
yeah i mean it was precious group muscle
metals as well
less
less
less needed in those days
but um but but nickel i mean you know
you strengthen tank armor with nickel
you play
uh handcuffs with nickel
and they need a lot of those yeah um
in the case of in the case of narelsk
it is so isolated they couldn't mine it
unless they had slave labor to do it
and then they realized they needed
geologists they needed scientists so
they just went up and arrested a whole
lot of geologists and then they shipped
them up there officially as prisoners in
but in practice just scientists
charles did stalin really believe in
this or was he just a power-hungry
maniac who was
he had many
megalomaniacal tendencies good question
it would be really nice to think that it
was because then you could kind of
excuse it
and then you could also kind of just
bypass the consequences of of wow if one
person can do that if one state can do
that if one man can bring on board
hundreds of thousands to actually
sign up to this cause and believe it's
totally fine for you to punish people in
that punishment camp i told it would be
great but um i don't think he was i i he
genuinely believed what he was doing he
he he was very very well versed in lenin
and marx he knew their theory and uh as
alexander solzhenitsyn you know the
great author of the the communist
manifesto has has said stalin didn't do
anything like archipelago not the
communist manifesto i beg your pardon
that is quite a slanderous
[Laughter]
yeah you see i'm just thinking i'm
already thinking too far you're on to
mark's already i'm on to mark's already
now now i like to stay off marks if i
can as long as i can most of my life um
yeah the girl like archipelago an
astonishing astonishing book and it's
now in one volume which um jordan
peterson has actually done the
introduction for
uh but um
yet stalin that's where we were at
before i yes made that little mistake a
little mistake um
if if you go back to stalin um
as far as socialism is concerned stalin
didn't make
it did do anything that lenin hadn't
already started lenin started the gulag
system
lenin uh ordered that the regime's
opponents would be locked up in a
concentration camp and up in one
concentration camp up near the um just
on the white sea archangel as we know it
there was a um there was an old
monastery they tended to use monasteries
because they probably imprisoned or shot
most of the inmates and they had thick
walls and lots of cells there was one
monastery hangmagori where
over the early two three four years just
after the revolution they shot 25 000
people there it really was a death camp
the rest were all slave labor camps for
the most part they shot people before
they came there um but uh lenin then
issued an order you know within two
years of the revolution that every
single city should have uh a gulag camp
uh a consultation camp which could hold
300 inmates
so within a few years there were 70 000
or so in camps around the place and then
this extraordinary island
uh the solovetsky islands group of
islands in the middle of the white sea
really became what again solzhenitsyn
called the first cancerous tumor
uh that metastasized to be the gulag
archipelago but by 1929 1930 there were
maybe 60 000 uh
prisoners there stalin had just come to
power and that was when he really uh
established the gulag system on an
official basis and gave it entirely to
the secret police it had been under kind
of dual uh management before entirely to
the secret police and then they they
just expanded it from there
um
extraordinary
i always think about this question which
is why we never taught this
why is it that
the nazi swastika is deservedly seen
as a
horrendous symbol of evil and of
oppression
but the hammer and sickle people just
shrug their shoulders they do yeah it's
interesting actually just on that point
we uh we do a raw show where we joke
about the events of the day and
for that we bought uh a soviet hat a
sort of south american or central
american revolutionary hat with the with
the star on it and a a german uh
hat as well and the day that we bought
it francis had a comedy gig that he was
going to and i gave him the the south
american hat and he just put it on and
walked outside and went to his gig sort
of for a joke between us but
we're fine if i wear my russian ushanka
with the soviet star no one would give a
damn if i wear the the che gubara
t-shirt great right great why
why is that it's a big question isn't it
it's a big question isn't it
um
you go go back
as far as the british left were
concerned between the wars everything
soviet was good
you know the spy anthony blunt who was
later on revealed he went up he was in
cambridge in the early 30s he he arrived
in cambridge he let had to leave for a
term he was going off studying somewhere
he came back he said when i came back to
university everyone had become communist
it was the only thing it was cool then
it was cool then it was cool when i was
when i was at school because most people
haven't the faintest idea what it means
they just think it's something warm and
and fuzzy we're all going to share and
whatever else so as far as the communism
is concerned leaving aside the soviet
symbols as far as the communism is
concerned people do not know the
communist manifesto is absolutely clear
the abolition of the family
you know you say oh communists want to
abolish the family don't be so
right-wing it's in there it's explicit
abolition of the family
abolition of all property ownership all
property ownership little corner shop
wouldn't exist in soviet russia taken
out of your hands if you were actually
trying to set up a private business
throw you into prison well that was a
crime under the statute yeah exactly
yeah so abolition abolition of property
abolition of uh the family abolition of
religion big big big one and abolition
of morality
you know those are in the communist
manifesto and i think you kind of got to
go up to a trotsky eye today and say
do you want to do that
do you believe as marx said and as
trotsky endorsed the only way to
transform society is by um
violent revolution
because marx was actually explicit you
know
violence is the midwife of the new
society there's only one way you can get
there is it's it's bloodshed
um
you need to ask these people do you
really believe that because that's what
these people you supposedly follow
um are actually are actually preaching i
i'm i'm writing a book at the moment i'm
about 80 finished that was my lock down
one really to get i got stuck in wales
for eight weeks which was
really pretty remarkable and i just
wrote and wrote and wrote wrote and and
i've i'm 80 finished on a book on
exactly this stuff i there's about 300
different quotes from marx and engels
and lenin and trotsky and and it's it's
just written to say this is what
it is do you really believe this but
they don't but it's something is
something nice and warm and fuzzy and
socialism is well different no to a to a
marxist socialism and communism are
interchangeable and no it's not social
democracy uh social democracy is
scandinavia and they say let's keep the
capitalist system but let's temper it to
make sure it's fair to the disadvantaged
that is not what socialism is democratic
socialism jeremy corbyn oh democratic
that must be good no it's exactly the
same is communism is socialism it is
what is in the manifesto well but jeremy
corbyn wasn't suggesting putting people
in gulags was he no he wasn't no he
wasn't but that's where people in his
situation need to be confronted he he
wrote he spoke about about marx he said
marx's philosophy and his insights are
really brilliant
well okay his insights are the only way
to transform society is through violent
revolution
yeah class war
um
there's a disconnect somewhere and
there's a lot of romanticism in it okay
there's a lot of romanticism in it i
think that's why some people as far as
communism
is concerned actually say oh yeah yeah
it's great we're all going to share
everything of course
you may i digress just a little while of
course um digress into what actually
happened when they really did try and do
something in the kibbutz system in
israel
uh because
you know the kubutz's were set up to
actually work out um a little local
version of communism
it was great to begin with but then it
got to the stage where nobody wanted to
take the garbage out
and they then started employing
outsiders to do the dirty jobs because
they were all meant to be sharing it
everyone was meant to be doing
everything equally but there were
actually things they didn't want to do
so they started employing outsiders and
then the kids were all shipped off to
communal quarters and taken away from
the the
um the family because
i mean
i could go up on a rabbit trail i won't
but when you read what the soviets
talked about as far as education and
children
we need to nationalize children said one
communist leader's wife we need to take
them away from the harmful influence of
the family i mean i read those bits and
i get angry because i i really do think
it's so inhuman but back to kibbutz um
uh i'll get to the end of it back to the
kibbutz and then the women didn't like
having common or clothing they didn't
like wearing clothes and then putting
them back into the communal wash house
and then just being given something that
was at whatever over their size and and
you know those ordinary
human things
you can't you can't marshal people on
mass just doesn't work people aren't
like that they're different and there
are freeloaders they found freeloaders
the idea of the communist utopia is that
there'll be no freeloaders everyone will
automatically just have so much
philanthropy in their hearts they just
want to help everyone no there's
freeloaders you know crime according to
marx comes only because people are
warped by the possession of private
property by others and the moment nobody
owns private property then crime will
disappear well we know that that's just
just you know it's counter-intuitive it
just doesn't work like that
you know charles i've lived in many
different places ironically i would say
the soviet union even in my childhood
which was in the 80s yeah was the most
doggy dog
yeah man against man we're all uh
we're all in russian we say we're all
wolves to each other yeah that's
that's
to man right that's the right way of
saying in english um
the the thing about this ideology is is
just not
it's great it's just not compatible with
humans yeah it's brilliant it sounds
incredibly good yeah it's just not
compatible with human beings do you
think that is part of the appeal and
that is why to this day there are people
who say well i'm a communist they'll go
on tv in this country and they'll say
i'm a comedy i'm literally a communist
and
i
i mean it's maybe not a fair question to
ask you what do you think she means by
that when she says that ashtaroka i am
literally a communist
because i know what that would mean to
me yeah i know what it would mean to me
but i don't think she has any idea
really what she's talking about
and and
i can't see inside i can't i
because i find it so hard i actually
can't see inside the minds of people who
are you know full luxury automated
communism um uh uh and all the rest is i
i can't i can't get my head we've
invited her on because i want to ask her
this question and not in any hostile way
i don't know i wonder what they mean
because it's fair to exchange ideas yeah
you you defend them if you're if you're
in a respectful environment this is
great that's great go for it and then as
and then but then you see you do get the
denial that comes in and this is this is
the other part of your question which i
i haven't kind of yet answered you know
you get uh sheamus milne who who worked
very closely with jeremy corbyn um
talking about the great social advances
for women that took place um in the
soviet union well it's great social
advantage is for women yeah yeah what
was going on at the same time
i mean you know
as you say a dog eat dog society because
for uh
70 years they have had the heart ripped
out of
property rights of of of all moral
rights i mean you know all moral
standards just just taken away it's it's
the revolution the revolutionary theory
is that that whatever suits the
revolution is okay so then that becomes
whatever suits me is okay um yeah i'll
just take what i want i mean after all
it all belongs to all of us everything's
belong to the state now so why not just
take it and then i'm not gonna work
because i'm gonna get paid anyway
um and the incentive is gone because
uh and and and and on but but you know
there's a there's there's that they
cover up they call all these excesses um
what is it the word
the communist party of britain today
fascinating you you need to find their
manifesto the road to socialism i i i
picked up a version which was um
you know maybe 10 years
ago or so but it gets revised every so
often and um you know they they address
stalin's excesses and they say just you
know these were kind of accidental
mistakes in the progress of communism
and what stalin did well they won't say
they won't say it's not real communism
because actually they're kind of star
and apologists but this is what you get
a lot of the time not real communism not
real communism not real communism so so
so what was it that went on in cambodia
with pol pot it wasn't real communism i
mean three million people were killed
that's not real communism real communism
is just
nice and warm and fuzzy and no it isn't
because if you're going to control and
take over every single part of the state
if you're going to take over private
property if you're going to take over
everything that any corporation owns you
have to do it by force no one's going to
give up all that stuff you have to do it
by force you have to be prepared to use
force and you have to then keep force in
there
marx was very explicit he said
when you got people who are resentful
and hating something
don't stop it
actually
use it
encourage it because that's what we want
to have weaponized and we'll see we see
that in left-wing politics today
weaponize hate
if you believe that class war is the
only way through to the new utopia
you're not interested in compromise
you're not interested in coming together
in finding a middle ground you're not
interested in the sharing of ideas you
don't actually want to reproduce more
you believe
class war is going to be what is going
to finally go into violence and then
when we have the revolution
you will take power you will take the
property of the the elite the privilege
the wealthy whatever they are and then
you will run it differently now you'll
they'll run it with the same human
frailty as anyone else will and actually
because then by then they've actually
got to run it for the whole country they
will be making decisions i mean this is
this was the thing in in russia wasn't
it you know um one factory somewhere in
the middle of nowhere is told how many
tins of baked beans it's going to
produce for the year and that's it
and and if that's not enough well you
don't get any more
and someone else has to produce all the
concrete and someone else has to produce
all the tractor tires um and everything
becomes socially planned and then that's
why you get conscripted labour forced
labor moved because if you're putting a
new factory somewhere and you don't have
the labor for it
well
you've got to move the labor so you just
round up a whole lot of people you just
reassign them for something so then you
can't choose your career
no no you can't be a doctor we've got
enough doctors already this year um you
can be a plumber we've got a plan we
need three thousand plumbers in the next
three years you can be a plumber but you
can't be a doctor or you want to be a
plumber you can't be a plumber you need
to be a doctor um it's not it's it's not
a kind of privileged thing on on the the
scale of professions that's how the
control filters in even if you're just
going to have all this happening in a
peaceful way without the violence you
still have to have total control over
your population
are you tired of using bulky old wallets
giving you a bulge where you don't want
it to be my old wallet was massive so it
brought all the ladies to the yard which
was a huge distraction and got in the
way of my esteemed work on trigonometry
bridge wallets have an incredible
solution for you this is mine sleek
stylish and with an industrial look to
it you can fit 12 cards with cash on the
back using a clip like this one or a
strap we've got one for the whole team
i've got one francis has one even our
producer anton has one but he's from
liverpool so he flogged his on the black
market the great thing about ridge is
that they give you a lifetime guarantee
which means if you want you can have
only one wallet for the rest of your
life ridge are so confident in the
quality of their product they will give
you 45 days to test drive their wallets
that means you can get the wallet use it
and if you don't like it you can return
it within 45 days because ridge is such
great guys they're going to give you
guys we interrupt this advert to tell
you that ridge wallets have increased
their discount to 15 for the holiday
season that's 15 for the holiday season
use a code trigger and get 15 off your
ridge wallet offer expires on december
the 7th so you better be quick
but we've seen these ideas they're like
herpes they go on the ground for a bit
yeah yeah and then they just flare up in
the summer of 2020 with the blm marches
and you know abolish capitalism yeah
abolish the family and i was there and
people who i thought were my friends i
mean they're not really friends of me
anymore because they got upset because i
criticized blm but they were going to me
oh this is brilliant i'm like
sourcing venezuela didn't really end
well didn't really end well but we see
it again and again and repackaged in a
different way and the leaders of blm
right when actually talking about
themselves oh you know we're well versed
in communist theory well they said we
are trained marxists we trained marxists
yeah yeah and that's when i was like
look i don't care i i i believe black
lives matter blah blah blah yeah small
small small exactly but if you are
talking to me about being a trained
marxist
yeah let's yeah you're not for me yeah
yeah i i see where you want to end that
you won't want to end up with the
overthrow of society as it is now
and and you will do whatever you can and
um i mean trotsky was the one who said
you know we'll deceive anyone we want to
because we'll hide our aims
trotsky was explicit on that you know
we're going to dupe all these people in
in in the west we're going to dupe all
our opponents because it's quite all
right just to lie and and deceive and
work our way in there to do stuff so you
don't believe these people when they say
oh no no we only want to do this we only
want to do that no if they are
doctrinaire marxists
they'll
they'll not have any moral qualms about
doing anything in order to be able to
get their ends and it's interesting
you're adding somewhat to my historical
understanding because i always thought
the main reason that
uh that the west failed to recognize the
evil of the soviet empire was that we
needed we the west i i now consider
myself part of the west i suppose i
don't the way
there we go the west needed the soviet
union to win the war yeah we needed the
soviet union and stalin and we win well
and we did and if it wasn't for the
soviet union it wouldn't have happened
right so
but what you're telling me is even in
the early 30s
when there was no need for that
whatsoever there was no war
certain people
in the west were ignoring it covering it
up there's a guy i don't remember his
name now who won a pulitzer
for covering up
yeah the the holodomor the starvation of
the ukrainian peasants um at the highest
level in the labour party i mean the
great labor saint i i think he's got
buildings named after him somewhere
around here george lansbury uh he became
labor leader in 1933 uh and and he said
the story about
slave camps in russia is an absolute
fabrication i i i'm paraphrasing because
i can't remember the exact quote but you
know he said it's absolutely not true
it's a free it's it's a completely free
state and then clement atlee and and
he's really interesting because he
totally turned around after the war but
clemente 1937 at the height of this 680
000 people being shot okay he goes off
to the uh soviet embassy for the
anniversary uh dinner of the 20th
celebration of the um of the revolution
and he gives a speech and i've seen that
the transcript of the speech and he says
you know people hate the soviet union
but they they they really hate the
soviet union because they don't want to
see a nation go forward
based on social justice
and you think
whoa
680 000 bodies is a lot of bodies
they're still uncovering them it's a lot
of justice you you you've got to you've
got a kiev kiefer's most extraordinary
city because you've got baby yeah there
where thirty thousand jews were shot by
the nazis but you go outside to begin
your forest and uh the the nkbd the
secret police planted trees over maybe a
hundred thousand dead including some of
the polls from cutting after the war
clement atlee absolutely brilliant what
had happened i think is that he'd been
in the wartime cabinet with churchill
and they saw what the soviets were doing
he and ernest bevin who became his
foreign secretary in the first labor
government after the war um
what churchill wrote about
the um
about warsaw
and how the soviets backed off at the
last minute in order to make sure that
all of the polish resistance were wiped
out by the germans and refused to allow
allied uh supply drops to go via soviet
aerodromes in order to be able to keep
these people going
the red the red army called on the poles
to rise up and then they stopped outside
the city
so these people were wiped out polish
history is resonant with events like
this but so
churchill said
i have
i have never spoken or seldom spoken to
a cabinet that was so somber and so
angry over what was going on
at he was there bevin was there and then
you get to the post-war period
and atlee is absolutely determined he's
not going to let communists in to the
labour party he is meeting with the head
of the security services to talk to him
and find out where communist
infiltration is going on and ernest
berbin writes a report for the whole
cabinet in 1947 48 couple of them where
he's talking about the threat to
civilization because of what's going on
with the repression of the eastern
european countries and saying this is a
threat to world civilization what's
happening with all these poor people in
country after country you know poland
and hungary and romania
bulgaria and all these states actually
being taken over by communists and and
supposedly free elections being
completely fixed and whatever else it's
fascinating because that was the labour
party at its best that was the labour
party at its most admirable really saw
the world as it is
it's interesting listening to your talk
because it's difficult for me because
it's my family history but also
i also notice as you talk
the the exact same thing maybe with not
so much the cover-up but apart from that
is happening right now with shenzhen in
china
and in hong kong
and potentially in taiwan eventually
hopefully not but
do you think
like right now
we don't do anything about what china is
doing because we can't yeah isn't that
basically why we don't do anything right
but i don't think we are seeing
well actually now that i think about it
we are seeing people trying to run cover
for for this we see american celebrities
who are being paid by china too
um
but why was the cup why was the cover-up
why were they so keen in the 30s and
others later i mean if you read the the
preface to animal farm in which george
orwell talks about how difficult it was
to get it published because it was
perceived that he was criticizing the
soviets which of course he was right uh
why was that all happening jars is it
just because these people thought well
we are we're socialists we believe in
the working class and we've got a you
know this is the utopia they're creating
or was there a more nefarious agenda was
it soviet infiltration were they funding
these people well there's
there's so many different ways i can
answer that because because
little rabbit show go back to the 1920s
the british trades union movement was
working hand in glove
with russians uh officially russian
trade delegates but actually just
russian espionage in order to be able to
try and bring the whole nation through
to revolution we nearly had a revolution
in 1920 um in order to be able to stop
british support for the polls
uh so there has been this
and i've just gone off on that rabbit
trail too far just breathing now that's
fine my question was
why were they covering this up why were
they not challenging more robustly which
are two separate questions of course
yeah yeah um
you look through the 1930s and you get
um you get
people like uh
the guy who is the editor of um major
left-wing journal
ah it's gone anyway very important man
well-known in labor intellectual circles
was basically saying you know
it's not really our part
to criticize the people who are trying
to build communism in russia yeah okay
things aren't going well but we
understand how in a revolutionary period
you know lives will be lost but the most
important thing is what's going to be
the end result okay
the same old thing you know if we're
going to
you you want to make an omelette you've
got to crack eggs kind of stuff so there
were these apologies going on um
there's no doubt that people were being
totally duped
by what was happening
stafford crips the
shadow attorney general in the
90s early 1930s 1933 3036 actually
probably around about then he was
actually saying in parliament where
where they were talking about some
british engineers who'd been arrested
and their russian counterparts were very
likely to be shot and there was even a
possibility that these british engineers
would be shot on spurious charges this
is the attorney shadow attorney general
stood up in parliament he said but you
know if the russian system is a system
of justice as i believe it is
then if the uh death sentence is passed
it must be carried out that's only fair
1936 people misunderstood uh what soviet
justice was they thought of law as being
impartial but they didn't even read the
most obvious
statements made by soviet leaders which
was that the courts were there entirely
to be the servant of the revolution
law according to marx bourgeois law is
entirely fixed by
the privileged class it's entirely
created for the prep for the protection
of their property that's why you see
today
um
very little respect amongst the left for
the courts
i mean
we could talk about written house but we
won't talk about right now but i mean i
mean look at that
courts fair no the courts are the
creation of the oppressor class for the
fulfillment of their purposes so then
you have the police um defund the police
uh
yeah um then you have abolish the army
get rid of the secret services all these
are considered to be the organs of the
state solely there to protect the
privileged that's hardwired into the
whole doctrine so so where where were
the russians to answer your question
involved in actually working with people
yes but british communists saw them as
colleagues
you know communism communism has no
national borders communism has no
national boundaries another reason why
you'll find on the left particularly
they don't care about immigration they
don't care about national boundaries
because in fact there is only one nation
that nation is the working class the
international working class um and they
want to do anything they can to break
down any sense of national identity as
well as the family in microcosm in the
major it's it's the nation that has to
be broken down so so yes but but i mean
these these these are our colleagues
these are the people that we are working
with to build world communism so so on
the one hand there is yes there's the
espionage side you know there's the
people they they managed to get in the
foreign office and elsewhere and and and
the cambridge seven and all that it was
it's seven i can't remember offhand um
but but
for the most part these people and
british trade unionists in the period i
don't really cover but through the 70s
you know all that industrial unrest um
they'd be quite happy sitting and having
a cup of coffee with with somebody from
the soviet embassy because there are
chums they're our friends
so i mean that's part of your answer
charles isn't the problem this well
i used to live in wimbledon and there
was a lovely coffee shop near to me run
by a the manager was a cuban guy and i
used to
go once or twice a week we used to sit
down and we used to talk we used to talk
about cuba we talk about communism we
used to talk about his experiences
growing up and i remember saying to him
joel why is it that communism is so
appealing to people in the west and he
said to me
the thing is francis is talking to
somebody about communism
is like saying to somebody who grew up
talking to a western about communism
it's like saying to somebody who grew up
in a very rich
privileged part of the city
don't go into the rough part of the city
don't go into that alley they've had no
experience of it they don't understand
it he said it's only when they're down
the alley it's only when they're turning
around it's only when they see someone
coming for them and it's only when they
feel the blow to the back of the head
will they truly understand what
communism is got it exactly you've got
it exactly and that's one of the reasons
why actually it's so interesting to see
people who have come from eastern
european countries coming to this
country and settling here because they
carry a totally different experience
they understand what it's like you go to
those nations now they are under no uh
they're under no doubt whatsoever the
the regime that continues basically on
some of the same principles and is still
run by a former secret policeman uh uh
is capable of what it was capable of
before you know they have a whole
history of suffering your own family you
know you you can see through this if
someone someone walks down the street
and they've got the shaker t-shirt on
them you know
you just said you don't understand
what lies behind this and i think that's
what drives me
um with all of this is that
for each of us
you know there's different things that
we can do but i am just passionate that
the real story is told that people
understand what lies behind these ideas
that are so cool you know i signed up to
be a communist when i was at school i
just thought it was really cool i bought
my communist manifesto i never read it i
didn't understand it was completely
beyond me um but just because it seemed
to be cool
and and we need to
i think i i just like to be able to
catch people before they really get
swept up in it and say okay do you
really want to buy into this do you
really understand what it is you're
buying into and i want the general
public to know what they would know in
ukraine today for instance you know they
have a history they know today four
o'clock when i meant to be here today's
the uh annual celebration of the
holomador lighting a candle at four
o'clock i changed my um uh my um
my twitter picture to a candle today
because these are the things we need to
keep commemorating and we need to keep
talking about this kids need to be
educated about this stuff today they
have they have no idea i mean this is
why i was a privilege i visited a school
this week i i did a number of was asked
to speak to a number of classes all ages
right the way from from 14 right the way
up to those who were leaving and going
on to uni and talk to them about this
and i think for for some of them even
though these subjects do come into their
school curriculum it's the human
experience of what people went through
that really really hits oh my goodness
me and and i have this thing i put up
these faces
on on the screen i put up these faces of
people and then the caption says pyodor
someone
peasant
shot
for counter-revolutionary activity and
then you see this woman come up you look
she just looks like a good ordinary
farm
laborer
and shot in this state and whatever else
and it just it goes on like and they
whoa these are people this is real
people this is real lives and they're
still finding the bodies all over
eastern europe they are and
i suppose the question there giles is
why have we not got a schindler's list
for the soviet union why is it not part
of our culture why we have we not
trained ourselves to recoil in disgust
from all of these symbols and from this
history which we don't get taught
because the soviets were on our side of
the nuremberg trials yeah
the soviets were able to claim
victor status against fascism and that
that you know that's the mantra today
we're anti-fascists uh before we could
be anti-racists the buzz word was
anti-fascism now anti-racism is it has
taken the place of that but that's the
the ante that we're part of so they were
but they were part of you know i i i i
went to a meeting um uh at the european
parliament some years back which was
held by eastern european
politicians and the title was why was
there no nuremberg for the crimes of
communism right and their joy was should
be but
yeah well i mean to say that those
particular politicians the soviet union
took half of poland
uh before uh he was ever attacked by
germany it also uh annexed latvia
lithuania estonia murdering
tens of thousands of people in offices
as you say and lots and lots and lots
and we could go on
um
it's
it's very difficult and you know as you
know i'm writing my first book about my
experiences in russia and the west and
what i'm seeing happening here which
i'll be very interested to read because
it's a fascinating idea yeah but the
thing that i'm trying to we've been
trying to address on the show for the
last three and a half years is
you know two people who broadly speaking
consider themselves sort of center-left
maybe more center for me center-left for
francis always sensible about this this
sort of stuff we suddenly saw these very
radical ideas
about race
about
uh sex and gender and sexuality uh the
just entering the public sphere entering
our world comedy the media the the
political
discourse suddenly turned in this way
which to us people who come from these
countries was really really troubling
are you troubled by what is happening
trouble by what's happening i also see
some familiar patterns we're back to the
same old oppressor
yeah we're back to the fact that those
who are the oppressed class are
[Music]
they can never repent enough because
they are they are tainted by their very
active being that's that that that's
that's way back there you know the
capitalist was irredeemable uh
working-class criminals were redeemable
because they were just they were just
corrupted by capitalism but but we have
that same thing we have we have the we
have the dispute over truth you know
this idea that this idea that that that
if you are
a white male you can have no idea about
what real truth is truth is whatever the
oppressed feel is their truth because
you will always be tainted by your
colonialist attitudes or by by whatever
it is that's driving you to keep your
privilege well that's just that's just a
straight transfer remarks and i'm not
saying that what's going on with wokism
or whatever you want to call it is
marxism but it it you might say it's
kind of like why are you not saying that
because a lot of people are saying well
i know a lot of people are saying that
um and i'm just trying to be i'm just
trying to be careful what i was about to
say is i think probably they are um you
know third generation down
cousin one off in other words the
ancestry is still there
haven't they just traded that this is
why i might disagree with you and
correct me i'm i'm very i'm i'm quite
prepared because i'm still thinking
through these ideas myself as am i as
amazing hence the question to me all i
see is they've swapped
capitalist bourgeois yeah for white or
male or straight or whatever you want
yeah and they've swapped working class
oppressed
subjugated for
my ethnic minority sexual minority uh
female etc or woman whatever that now
means right all that to me i don't see
any difference yeah i think i i think
i'd go along with that i think i'll go
along with that i'm just conscious at
the same time we've still got
conventional old-fashioned marxists yeah
yeah alongside that yeah that's why i
call them
neo marxists yeah that's that yeah so
we've got the marxist and the
neo-marxism yeah that i'm i'm totally
with you i i don't think there's
anything i would uh disagree with on
that so what do we do about it josh oh
wow what does what does one do about it
what does one do about it well it needs
courage first of all um it needs courage
from people i mean like you guys you
know you stood up uh weren't really
aware of what you were doing you just no
come on i'm not going to stand for this
and then bang
whatever happened to you in your various
careers as they exploded or or imploded
rather
and i think it needs people everywhere
who who who see what's going on it needs
them
to say no i'm gonna stand against this
someone said the other day you know the
the frog in the hot water saucepan is
just absolutely a fiction i don't care
if it's a fiction because that's
actually what is happening to a lot of
people they are backed into a corner and
they just ah i can't be bothered to
fight this it's such an overwhelming
torrent
how can you stand up and i think people
need to i tell you what i would like to
see
i would like to see a movement actually
founded which could draw together all
these different constituencies you know
we've got
we've got mostly gender critical
feminists who are really able to stand
up against the trans issue
we've got other people um from different
areas of life i would like to see some
horrible if we could get some kind of
coalition of people united i talk to
people i go to i got to say you know we
have dinner 13 people around a table
some names and faces that quite well
known there and we're all saying what
should we do i'm talking to
someone else he said i'm meeting with a
whole lot of people and we're all
everyone's just ringing their hands and
they're just saying what's going to
happen what what can we do is there
anything we can do is it just you know
is it
so i i don't know what a movement looks
like but you see what's happening in
america among parents
now you see parents is ordinary people
who say no
you're not gonna do this stuff to my
kids and i am going to stop it happening
i am going to publicize it happening
we've got christopher ruffo doing all
his incredible work and as a result
because of his prominence he's getting
all these these secret documents leaked
to him from one place after another i
think that's absolutely brilliant and
you know people may criticize americans
for their independence and their
belligerence and whatever else but
there's something in the american
character which says uh uh i'm gonna
stand up against this this is they
didn't realize it's part of their
culture i think we're much more
compliant here well you know i mean
teacher knows best i mustn't really
complain about what teacher does or
whatever i'd like to see i'd like to see
not just the intellectuals alerted to
this because in a way in some places
they have quite a limited uh i mean you
have a big you have a big uh
constituency
but you know if you're a university
professor
there's a limit to the influence you've
got but if if if you know you're a whole
movement of of of ordinary people out
there the general public that's when
this stuff starts to catch on
what it looks like i have no idea but
but it's been something i've been
mulling over now for two three years so
maybe we do need a revolution
yeah we need a peaceful respectful
revolution but one that's got courage
perfect and on that note charles thank
you so much for coming on the show if
people want to find you online where
would be the best place to be i am on
twitter at giles ud and of course people
should buy the book labor yeah well it's
just being reprinted in a couple of
weeks time so it'll be out new edition
my publishers took one look at the thick
brick and said we just can't afford to
do that again so i'm actually doing it
myself so they'll be on my website
surely well our final question as you
know as always is what's the one thing
no one is talking about that we really
should be
what we've just been talking about so we
have been talking about it which is good
and we need to do a lot more of that
fantastic well we're going to ask you a
couple of questions for our locals but
in the meantime charles yud thank you so
much for coming on this it's been my
real pleasure i've just loved the time
it's been great having you on and of
course thank you so much for watching
and listening we'll see you with another
brilliant episode i was going to say
like this one i probably won't be quite
like this one i won't be crying nearly
as much uh we'll see with another
brilliant episode or raw show all of
them go out 7pm uk time and if you like
your trigonometry on the go it's also
available as a podcast take care and see
you soon guys
we hope you've enjoyed this incredible
interview remember to subscribe and hit
the bell button so that you never miss
another fantastic episode and if you
believe that the work we do here at
trigonometry is important support us by
joining our locals community using the
link below